foreign
let's go to Shirley in Tampa Florida
what's up Shirley
Shirley you there
yes can you hear me I can hear you
what's happening
how are you partying what are you up to
nothing just here on my early lunch
break to do this call early lunch break
it's like a late breakfast at best good
for you yeah it's kind of basically when
does your shift start
I start at 8am that is unacceptable you
need a new job all right so what's up
what's up
all right so
um so I've been going through a divorce
um
finalized uh we'll be finalized towards
the beginning of July but um man this
thing is tough when I say it it's tough
It's like unlike something I've ever
been through before and it's definitely
taught me a lot about myself but it's
also put a lot into perspective for just
many things that I'm coming to realize
not like like I said like emotionally
mentally and even financially like
relying on this person for so long that
once that was gone I completely went
into like a survival mode if that makes
sense of course yeah if you did if you
had done anything less than going to
survival mode there'd be something
you wouldn't be operating right
so good for you that's that was exactly
the right thing for you and your body uh
what happened
uh so him and I were about we were
together for six years
um we did do long distance for four
years I actually lived in Nebraska and
um I met him in Vegas that's also a very
long story I got a girl way to go surely
um all good choices come out of famous
marriages
Vegas but uh he shortly moved here back
to Florida and I was doing Village in
Nebraska so I
cuz I had a full ride
um so I ended up moving here covet of
2020 and uh you know just I think first
just coming into the relationship like
from not from a honeymoon phase to being
around each other and ever living with
each other was just like a completely
180 for both of us
you say that like you're surprised like
man we we
played lovers on the internet for four
years but then when we got around each
other it was weird yes really of course
it's weird
so so it sounds like it sounded like
after y'all got together it didn't last
long
uh no so I mean we held it out together
for about three years
um but it kind of just recently ended so
Christmas of this year of past year um
unfortunately you know he did get
physical with me
um so I'm so sorry I can't lie and say
that was the first time you got physical
with me you know so what was it what was
it about this time that you said that's
enough
um it's funny and I don't want to say
it's funny because even then
it wasn't until you know like his family
kind of got involved because it was
around his family
um so
that was kind of like the straw that
broke the camel's back it was like okay
what are what are we doing here so we
have talked about it after it all that
happened and we were like okay because
we actually did not get married till
this past October
um so we were only married for about
three months and um well in in in it
would be a very rare relationship
that there's that kind of physical abuse
when I say that kind I mean repetitive
it happens more than just one time
it's so egregious that the person's
family gets involved
and probably in defense of you
that there isn't all sorts of other
abuse or all sorts of other
really taking your soul from you and
putting it in a box and putting that and
bearing in the backyard
you know what I'm saying
like you yeah it's very common to lose
all of you
yeah definitely I mean when that kind of
just when they got involved it was like
a really like a a step back and that's
when we kind of both sat down and said
okay well now we're married like should
we try marriage counseling should we no
he should try not hitting you
try something yeah yeah definitely um
that's the thing so so what's your
question how can I help you
so my question here is I'm I'm just
having a very hard time forgiving him
like
walk away
walk away yeah
what you're hoping to do is you're
hoping to try to make this thing right
and you can't
yeah
and yeah
I think I'm trying to keep like you said
you know walking away and taking control
and matters in my own hands and why does
that why why who told you and this is a
long
um pull through narrative in your life I
would be willing to bet money
that you are not good enough or smart
enough or strong enough to do things on
your own for a while who told you that
because it's myself actually it's bull
crap on a stick yeah but you you earned
that story somewhere
yeah where'd that come from
I honestly think it was just kind of my
my upbringing uh with my like you know
my relationship with family and siblings
just kind of like
seeing how life played out in certain
areas and also having a lot of
abandonment issues like my father
passing away when I was nine and you
know my mom getting married again and my
sister leaving to college and it was
just kind of like
as soon as this happened and actually he
was the one to walk away from it
um immediately I went into that like
abandon like I'm not good enough again
here I am
what were you a full ride student what
were you studying
I studied criminology and criminal
justice
what are you what are you going to do
with with that degree
so I actually uh attempted to become a
cop okay
um so I got through the process through
two different counties and again I got
completely through the whole process but
I didn't get chosen from the candidate
pool so then those were those other
underlying issues were like okay here I
am again not good enough so then I just
started just doing like smaller jobs on
the side and then like now I'm just I'm
personal training did they give you
feedback as to why
uh
uh no it was just more so like
the pool I would continue to re-enter
that pool there are such severe
um candidate choices in this country
that somebody with your academic
credentials
um
that a university decided looked at you
and said we're gonna let you go for free
that's how bad we want you here
um somebody with that level of academic
um ability not to mention your personal
training ability like you would be a
star candidate across the country
thank you I appreciate that well I I
just I I mean that's my world that's the
guys I hang out with I know those guys
and
um
they are in in many counties across the
country they're desperate for people to
come in and say I want to be a part of
helping this community and so what I
don't want you to do is to circle the
wagons in one of the most desirable
places to live in the United States
where there happens to be a surplus of
candidates that's just that's just very
rare
but bigger than that
at some point you're gonna fall right
back into somebody else
who's going to put their ring through
your nose and drag you around their life
unless you decide for the first time
since you were a little bitty girl
that what I want matters and what I need
matters
and the life that I have laid out in
front of me these dreams that I have
I get to see them to fulfillment
and of course having a partner in that
Adventure would be great but I'm worth
more than getting hit
I'm worth more than getting stolen from
because I guarantee you he took your
money worth more than being called
stupid and ridiculous because I didn't
get a particular job and I know he Cut
You Down
like you're you're worth more than all
of that right
yeah definitely do you believe that
see I I see it and I know it but it's so
hard when you know you are in that
mindset that's right
I like I do not I do not believe it like
there's moments where I'm like all right
I'm doing this I'm getting through it
you know like I'm capable of it but then
there are those moments where you're
just like
am I low am I here's your here's a plan
moving forward okay
when we get off this call I want you to
go down to Walmart or just a local store
and I want you to get yourself a small
Journal okay
and I want you to write down in that
journal
four or five I am statements that are
going to be your new identity that
you're going to live into
I am Shirley and I'm worth being loved
I'm Shirley
and things of unspeakable evil have
happened to me in the past
and I'm about going forward I'm surely
and I'm a steward of my mind and my body
and I want you to put those things down
and then I want you to come up with four
or five things not thoughts you can
think
or cultures sick with enough thinking
and feeling
I want you to put four or five things
that you can do
right okay
that come hell or high water unless
you're sick that you're gonna do those
things every day you're gonna begin to
lean in and practice these new
identities
okay another thing you gotta do for the
first time in your life and it's going
to cost you some money and I want you to
say for the first time Shirley's worth
this is you need to call a counselor
call my friends at better help they'll
hook you up or
um call a local counselor there in Tampa
I think it'd be good for you to see
somebody in person and I want you to
walk in and sit down and say my dad died
when I was nine
my mom brought another man into the
house when I was 11. my sister left when
I was 14.
I just got out of an abusive marriage
I'm sick and tired of everybody leaving
me and I'm sick and tired of my body
approaching every relationship I zoom
about to be left I'm ready to heal I
want you to have that exact sentence I
want you to write it down and read that
to the therapist
because I don't think you need therapy
we're just going to sit and talk and
chit chat and talk and chit chat and
talk and chit chat you have to heal your
body
that is so ready for everybody to leave
you that you will you will accept
anybody and anything
even somebody physically harming you
you're worth so so much more Shirley
so much more
and your friends know it
your ex's family knows it
I know it there's one person left that
needs to know it and that's you and it's
just gonna take some healing because
you've been through hell and back and
you and I could probably sit and talk
for a couple hours and you could tell me
some stories that would that would make
my skin crawl
but you're here and you made it
now you get to decide what are we going
to do next
my hope is for the first time
you're gonna put Shirley first and begin
to love Shirley
that's the path to peace my sister
hang on the line I'm going to send you a
couple of things I'm going to send you
Total Money Makeover and a year
subscription to Financial Peace
University I work at Ramsey Solutions
we're going to teach you how to work
your how to take care of your money I'm
also going to send you a copy of my book
own your past change your future about
dealing with life after it deals with
you what do you do next
and also I want you to stay on the line
I'm gonna send you a copy of my friend
Ken Coleman's book paycheck to purpose
we're going to help you find that police
officer job that is right for you and it
is out there in this country I promise
you I promise you and on the line I'm
going to send you all that stuff to get
you launched out of this abusive
relationship and into the next thing